so your baking show nailed it was
nominated for an Emmy right yes yes
RuPaul's Drag Race which I get it it's
my favorite show I truly love it it's
hilarious it's so good yeah did you get
to meet anybody cool have you ever been
to the Emmys before no I've never been
to the all of our America I just mean
like I mean now I have a teenager but
before you know singers don't generally
know I guess so what was my first Emmys
it was very glamorous I loved it there
was just famous people very close to you
which is like a real delight yeah mérida
lie well yes but they're all well
they're walking around with publicist so
they can't have they don't have time to
be mean you know yeah but uh I saw Viola
Davis and I loved Viola Davis I also saw
her on a plane recently and I was like I
need to talk to her but then I was like
she's living her life don't do it so I
didn't do it but then at the Emmys I was
like this is a work event I could talk
to whoever I watched I just pitched it
to people on your sodas and I was like I
am bothering you box I need you to know
I love you and she truly was like half
eating a hamburger I was like I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this